vamos a la revista de prensa Como cada
mañana con Rosa Pérez más deu Rosa Buen
día para usted Buenos días Ángela Bueno
vamos a empezar con el periódico francés
Liberación que dedica a su portada a
Ucrania el titular liberación de los
ucranianos exactamente y este es un
ejemplo de cómo la prensa empieza a
cubrir Este primer año de guerra que se
cumple concretamente este viernes 24 de
febrero no Y en este caso Liberación
pues para la ocasión habla con
voluntarios refugiados soldados civiles
o artistas que dice este periódico en su
portada no con el logo cambiado de este
rojo tradicional a los colores de la
bandera ucraniana amarillo y azul dice
que lo que decíamos no varios ucranianos
de distintos perfiles explican al
periódico El horror el miedo pero
también sus esperanzas
bien Y es que esta semana empezó con
toda la energía con la llegada sorpresa
de biden aquí Efe que está en la prensa
de la los medios apenas minutos antes de
que se viera él caminando por las calles
de kiev no muy campante exactamente y
uno de los primeros a medios en publicar
la noticia ha sido el medio ucraniano
kief independent que titula esta
información en desarrollo de la
siguiente forma biden visita kiev por
sorpresa y se reúne con selenskip además
dice que Bueno recuerda que se trata de
la primera visita de biden a Ucrania en
calidad de presidente no y que junto con
selensky han visitado el Memorial
dedicado cito textualmente del artículo
a honrar los soldados ucranianos caídos
en la guerra de Rusia contra Ucrania
desde 2014 por otro lado señalan que al
tiempo que vayan llegaba a Ucrania la
Casa Blanca ha publicado un comunicado
en el que promete más sanciones para
Rusia y también más armamento para
Ucrania más sistemas de defensa
antiaérea y esto este artículo lo
vincula recordando que es de lensky
visitó Washington en diciembre siendo
esa visita la primera vez que ucraniano
salía de su país desde que empezó la
invasión rusa y que en ese momento biden
le prometió vamos a dar a Ucrania lo que
necesite para vencer en el campo de
batalla no y precisamente esto lo
recuerda este periódico en el momento
que está sobre la mesa todo el debate a
raíz de la petición de Ucrania de que
sus aliados de La otan le provean con
aviones de combate esta mañana sonaban
las alertas en kief estas sirenas de
alarma cada vez que hay bombardeos pero
no esta vez era biden el que anunciaba
su visita ahora Esta visita sorpresa se
enmarca Precisamente en un viaje que sí
estaba previsto de biden hacia Polonia
el periódico estadounidense político
titula que se trata de uno de los
momentos decisivos de su presidencia y
no es para menos exactamente y dice que
a pesar de que públicamente va a decir
que Estados Unidos continuará apoyando a
Ucrania hasta la victoria y que se
reúnen en este caso se va a reunir con
el presidente de Polonia que ha sido uno
de los países más insistentes en el
envío de armamento para ayudar a Ucrania
recordemos que Polonia fue uno de los
promotores de la envío de tanques a
Ucrania dice biden sabe así como las
autoridades estadounidenses que ya han
advertido ashelensky que este envío de
armamento puede ser finito que por un
lado Europa empieza a verse sobrepasada
en su capacidad militar Y que por otro
lado una cámara de mayoría republicana
en Estados Unidos puede decantar La
balanza y puede hacer que en un momento
pues Estados Unidos no continúe apoyando
a Ucrania al mismo ritmo no y que por
último según la inteligencia de Estados
Unidos Putin no muestra signos de
vacilar en su promesa de controlar toda
Ucrania textualmente dice este artículo
de político que se basa en dos ventajas
superioridad numérica incluyendo Los
mercenarios de Wagner y también el tener
el tiempo a su favor y sin embargo lo
que dice la visita de biden es que se
está perdiendo estrategia por parte de
Rusia ahora vamos ahora Rosa el medio
ruso Commerce Y es que dice que la
comisión europea consideraba que la
sobre el North Stream es una
especulación Esta es una noticia de la
que hemos hablado bastante con usted
aquí en revista de prensa no exactamente
Ángela y lo recordamos para las personas
que no sepan de qué estamos hablando que
si hay mujeres publicó el ocho de
febrero un artículo titulado como
Estados Unidos eliminó el nord Stream en
el que plantea que el ataque fue ideado
por la Cia en cooperación a con Noruega
y por deseo del presidente Joe en el
ataque las explosiones contra el y que
la operación encubierta se ejecutó en
junio de 2022 cuando unos buzos de la
marina estadounidense aprovecharon unos
ejercicios anuales y rutinarios de la
otan en el mar Báltico para colocar
explosivos en las tuberías de los
nordstream que fueron detonadas tres
meses después por el ejército de Noruega
el texto ha generado mucha polémica de
hecho la Casa Blanca lo ha calificado de
ficción y por eso nosotros quisimos
hablar con este fin de semana y una de
las preguntas que lo hicimos fue
cree que puede publicar algo que hiciera
imposible que la Casa Blanca negara su
autoría Respecto a los ataques contra
los nordstream y vamos a ver rápidamente
lo que nos respondió a esta pregunta
pero la entrevista completa La pueden
ver por supuesto en nuestros en nuestras
redes sociales y en 24.com
en la casa blanca si usted quiere saber
lo que yo pienso yo pienso que la Casa
Blanca sin importar lo que salga no va a
decir nunca que lo hicieron
me apunto nunca se van a sentar ahí y
van a dejar que pase y van a pegarse lo
que dijeron porque las implicaciones de
lo que hicieron son extremos Usted cree
que le van a decir a Europa miren
decidimos que es mejor para ustedes no
tener ningún tipo de combustible que
todas sus fábricas se cierren porque nos
preocupan que ustedes no pueden
respaldarlos respaldarlos
Estados Unidos a Europa no deja de ser
polémica Rosa y en los televidentes Pues
que vean la entrevista completa no
efectivamente gracias a usted gracias
Ángela